We can represent most things by a list of properties and
their values. Think about how you would represent you or your
cell phone, the email in your inbox. Maybe even events, such
as the last party you attended. Mostly a list of key value
pairs, right. Key value pairs or dictionaries as they're called in
Python, make a lot of sense as a way to represent data.
Primarily because it's so natural to represent so much of the
data we care about this way. Let's think about the you example
for a minute. In my case, some of the
features might be. Eyes, brown. Hair, brown. Height, 6'2.
Weight, I'll leave that as an exercise for the
viewer. Note that name pairs are very different from documents.
With the document, we have sections, containing subsections, containing
paragraphs, containing sentences. This type of nesting or tree
structure is exactly the type of structure that XML
was designed to work with. In practice you'll find that
XML is used for many purposes, even those for which it's probably not the
best choice, and others for which one could argue it's not appropriate. In order
to ensure you're ready to wrangle XML in all its forms, we'll give you
some practice working with applications of XML,
to both documents and key value data.